The original impulse behind the book was
a recognition I've had.
There are very many people who don't
really enjoy what they do or perhaps in
how they live.
They don't enjoy the work they do and
they sort of tolerate it,
you know,
they got through the week and they wait
for the weekend.
Was a lot of evidence of that.
By that.
I love it.
Studies have shown that's massive
disengagement at the workplace and yet I
also meet people who love what they do
and they couldn't really imagine doing
anything else.
If you said to them,
why don't you do something else for a
change,
they really wouldn't know what you meant
to say,
but this isn't what I do.
It's it's who I am and they couldn't be
veterinarians,
pathologists,
they could be dancers,
musicians,
they could be teachers,
homemakers,
you name it.
If you can think of a human activity or
occupation,
there'll be people who love it and live
for it and others who couldn't bear it.
So I was just always intrigued by the
difference between these two ways of
being and the difference it makes.
I think it has really considered the
implications.
It has implications that are social and
character.
You know,
if we have communities where launch
trenches of the population of simply
detach this engaged and interested.
Of course it has big consequences if
people are disengaged at work.
It has large consequences.
Now,
I'm not suggesting for a minute that if
every finds that relevant,
it will solve every social problem we
face,
but I'm certainly saying it would help
and my longterm convictions always be in
that we all have the talents and the
potential for engagement and we should
explore it.
I have fallen into using the phrase the
other climate crisis and I think it has
a residence.
What I mean by it is that we've become
used to the fact now at least I hope we
have.
That is a crisis in the world's natural
resources,
but I also think there is a crisis in
our human resources and how we use them.
And one of the themes of the book is to
make an analogy between the natural
world and and the way our lives
operating.
And we tend to think that we were
persuaded ourselves because we live in
cities like New York or la or wherever
they were,
somehow independent of nature.
And of course we're not where organic
creatures we live and we die and we,
uh,
we're subject to the own season,
the seasons of our own lives,
and just like the earth,
it seems to me,
human resources often buried deep
beneath the surface.
You can spend your whole life completely
oblivious to some talent you may have
because the opportunity never showed up
for you to discover it or to develop it.
So that's the broad aim of the book,
is to dig down more deeply into what it
means to be in your element,
but also the book is really focused on
providing some practical support,
health and exercises.
Then if that's the journey that your
interest in taking for yourself or for
people who know and love your children
or people you work with,
then I hope you'll stay
with us here on,
on big thing.
Mentor.